if we
re-ran earth a million times
would what we got now be the most
special thing
and how often would it be so
scientifically speaking
how repeatable is this experiment
so this whole cognitive revolution yes
maybe not maybe not basically
i feel that the longevity of
you know dinosaurs suggest that it was
not quite inevitable
that we um that we humans eventually
uh made it but you're also implying one
thing here
you're saying you're implying that
humans also don't have this longevity
this is the interesting question so with
the fermi paradox
the idea that the basic question is like
if if the universe has a lot of uh alien
life forms in it why haven't we seen
them
yeah and one thought is that there's a
great filter or multiple great filters
that basically would destroy intelligent
civilizations like we
this thing that we you know this
multi-folding brain that can
keeps growing may not be such a big
feature it might be useful for survival
but it like takes us down a uh
side road that is a very short one with
a quick dead end what do you think about
that
so i think the universe is enormous
not just in space but also in time
and the the pretense that
you know the last blink of an incident
that we've been able to send radio waves
is when somebody should have been paying
attention to our planet
he's a little ridiculous so my
you know what i love about star wars yes
is
a long long time ago in a galaxy far far
away it's not like some distant future
it's a long long time ago
what i love about it is that basically
says you know evolution
and civilization are just so
recent in you know on earth
like there's countless other planets
that have probably all kinds of life
forms
multicellular perhaps and so and so
forth
um but the fact that humanity has only
been
listening and emitting for just this
tiny little
means that any of these you know alien
civilizations would need to be paying
attention to every single insignificant
planet out there
and you know again i mean the movie
contact
and the book is just so beautiful this
whole concept of
we don't need to travel physically we
can travel as light
we can send instructions for people to
create machines
that will allow us to beam down light
and recreate ourselves
and in the book you know the aliens
actually take over
they're not as friendly but you know
this concept that
we have to eventually go and conquer
every planet i mean i think that
yes we will become a galactic species so
you you have
um hope well you said thanks oh of
course of course i mean hope now that
we've made it
so far you we so you think i made it oh
gosh
i feel that you know cognition the
cognition as an evolutionary trait has
won over
in our planet there's no doubt that
we've made it so basically humans
have won the battle for you know
uh dominance it wasn't necessarily the
case with dinosaurs like
i mean yes you know there's some
claims of intelligence and if you look
at jurassic park yeah sure whatever
but you know they just don't have the
hardware for it
yeah and humans have the hardware
there's no doubt that mammals
have a dramatically improved hardware
for cognition
over dinosaurs like basically there's
universes where strength went out
and in our planet in our you know
particular version
of whatever happened in this planet
cognition went out
and it's kind of cool i mean it's it's a
privilege right
but it's kind of like living in boston
instead of i don't know some um
middle uh middle age uh place where
everybody's like hitting each other
with uh you know uh weapons and sticks
back to the lucky one song i mean we are
the lucky ones
but the flip side of that uh is that
this hardware also allows us to develop
weapons and methods of destroying
ourselves
so you again i want to go back to pinker
yeah and the better angels of our nature
the whole concept that civilization
and the act of civilizing has
dramatically reduced violence
dramatically if you look you know
at every scale as soon as
organization comes the state basically
owns the right to violence and
eventually
the state gives that right of
governance to the people but but
violence has been eliminated by that
state
so this whole concept of central
governance
and people agreeing to live together and
share responsibilities and duties
and you know all of that is something
that has led
so much to less violence less death less
suffering less you know poverty less
um you know war i mean
yes we have the capability to destroy
ourselves
but the arc of civilization
has led to much much less destruction
much much less war and much more peace
and of course there's blips back and
forth
and you know there are setbacks but
again
the moral arc of the universe
you